Whether you're working from home, remotely or even on the road,...
...the way we live and work is always changing.
Working in a changing environment can create worry and feelings of stress,...
...uncertainty and loneliness, which can have a negative effect on our mental health.
However, there are things you can do to help you stay mentally healthy...
...in your workplace no matter where that is.
Keep to a routine with clear start and finish times in a designated workspace.
Be sure to take regular breaks, get physical exercise and switch off after work.
If you're able to, participate in opportunities that let you reconnect with co-workers.
Schedule regular catch-ups and chats with your colleagues...
...either online or over the phone to maintain connections and stay in touch.
Always be on the lookout for signs that someone is struggling.
Look for changes in communication and behaviour.
Are they posting less?
Are they answering your calls?
Is there a change in their tone or language?
And then, trust your gut and check in with them.
It's okay to say you're not okay.
Many organisations offer free mental health support services...
...or your workplace may have an employee assistance program available.
If you start to feel overwhelmed or anxious, seek support immediately.
For free tools and resources to support managers and workers stay mentally healthy,...
...visit mentalhealthatwork.nsw.gov.au.